I have never seen anything like this
maybe ever
a soaking wet Donald Trump
why can't they turn up the AC it's his
own house after all a soaking wet Donald
Trump who has barely left his home in
the month since he declared he was
running for president why isn't he
leaving his house we don't know was
interviewed by his own lawyer as if
she's a news anchor journalist on oan
and it still was a disastrous interview
Christina Bob is an anchor on oan one
America news and she is one of Donald
Trump's lawyers who tried to run
interference during the entire FBI
Mar-A-Lago search warrant She
interviewed Trump as if it's just a
journalist and it was still so
humiliating for Donald Trump why is he
always soaking wet we don't know is it
hyperhidrosis is it flop sweat we just
don't know listen to this first segment
collect committee they're looking at
everything other than two things
they don't want to know about Nancy
Pelosi turning down ten thousand
soldiers because she didn't
Nancy Pelosi did not turn down ten
thousand soldiers Trump insists he asked
for ten thousand soldiers there is not a
shred of evidence that Donald Trump made
that request for January 6th she didn't
look like the look now if you had ten
thousand soldiers for you know hundreds
of people they wouldn't have gotten
anywhere near the place it would now
consider how funny it is that when it
comes to the turnout in General on
January 6th Trump says there might have
been a million people at his speech at
which he encouraged them to go to the
Capitol but now he says well there were
only a few hundred people at the Capitol
now of course both are lies there were
not a million people at his speech and
there were way more than a few hundred
people there are 700 defendants who
allegedly committed crimes at the
Capitol there were of course thousands
tens of thousands of people but every
number Trump gives is a lie it would
have been there would have been no no
January 6th there wouldn't have been
been a January sixth so might be the
problem oh no well there are a lot of
people that think they wanted it but
she's trying to help him
but he won't take the the the life
preserver but if you had soldiers
circling and I recommended it strongly
that's a lie but it's her decision she's
the one that has to make the decision
that's also a lie and nobody likes
talking about that but we recommend it
because I knew that a lot of people were
coming down they were coming down
because they thought the election was
rigged we know and they were right yeah
but that's why they were coming down and
uh that's why they don't want to talk
about that and they don't want to talk
about the rigged election they all they
want to talk about is
the people and those people are being we
we just keep focusing on all of the
people that Trump motivated to commit
acts of violence and criminality but not
the fact that the election was rigged
because the election wasn't rigged we
did many of them are being treated
unbelievably unfairly compare that to
what happened in the riots where black
lives matter and antifa
killed people they killed people I have
found no evidence that black lives
matter and antifa killed people there's
an article that's a couple years old
from the guardian which says
anti-fascists linked to zero murders in
the U.S in 25 years uh that data has
changed there is now one homicide in the
U.S that has been tentatively linked to
a self-described anti-fascist
I I don't think it's convenient to Trump
to Compare the numbers to right-wing
violence in the United States let's go
to a little bit more of this interview
and it is really wacky
would look as obviously bad as this is
by the way a compilation from our friend
Aaron rupar it does if it hadn't been so
starkly contrasted with your huge
success of an Administration there's
that's a beautiful journalistic question
huh your Administration was so good is
that part of why Biden looks terrible is
the Keystone Pipeline Keystone XL yeah
it was all done that was starting and
you know the sad part is that's a union
job and the union head
endorse Biden
and like immediately after he gets into
office he terminates the Keystone
Pipeline right and that Union should get
rid of that guy and I'll guarantee you
the union workers voted for me I bet you
most of them voted for me but I bet you
they didn't the head of the Union
endorsed Biden and then Biden terminated
it immediately he didn't say he was
going to said he was going to look it
over right
but he didn't it was another lie see
that's the big lie not us they're the
big lie just it's just free word
association and Christina Bob is
desperate to help but she just can't and
they're the big lie on the election too
not us it's the exact opposite right and
then you have the unselect committee
they're looking at everything other than
two things yeah so then that's the
segment we already saw let's skip
forward a little bit to just a little
more Minneapolis they burned down look
at what happened in Seattle where they
took over a big part of the city yeah
and Portland just like people put up
wooden sofrans because they get knocked
down as fast as they put them up and
people are getting killed and nothing
happens to those people and yet with the
other
it's it's like incredible not only
nothing happens you have people
Democrats
trying to get bail money to get them out
when most of them are in jail anyway so
it doesn't matter but compare that
treatment with the treatment that these
people are getting
and it's just a very very unfair
situation
it's it's just all over the place Trump
now cares about pre-trial detention when
it comes to the people that committed
acts of violence defending him right sir
and I know we're almost out of time but
I wanted to ask you one more as riveting
as this is sir we are almost out of time
Trump's like I'll say for hours I'm not
doing anything I don't leave my house
this is just one of the many great
pictures that you pull for your book
about the rallies oh God what do you
think about the rallies I know you have
one coming up and South Carolina South
Carolina we have another one coming up
in Georgia very soon no the rallies are
incredible the rallies honestly and you
know it because you go to some of them
they're bigger now than they were before
the election that's of course untrue and
Donald Trump does appear to be getting
back into the rallies what the point of
the rallies will be we don't know but at
least in theory he's a presidential
candidate I guess he'll talk about the
fact that he's running wacky stuff as
delusional as ever let's talk about one
bit of not so good news for for the
failed former president
You Love non-fiction books you love
learning as much as you can about
politics and economics and history and
science but you just don't have the time
to read every book that you want to read
that's why I'm such a big fan of
blinkist it's the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
them down into an explainer that you can
read or listen to in 15 minutes and get
the most important insights from the
book you take a topic you've been
wanting to explore and you can consume
10 books about it in an afternoon it
gives you a meaningful overview and
insight into what other books you might
want to read in full I just read welcome
to the universe it's Neil deGrasse
Tyson's latest book that's exactly the
type of book that I would love to have
the time to read but my stack of books
is already so big my girlfriend and I
also use the blinkist connect feature to
share and discuss books with one another
with one account and it makes a great
eight last minute holiday gift you can
try blinkist free for seven days and get
25 off a subscription at blinkist.com
Pacman the link is down below